What surprises me is I was reading this
paper, I went on and had a further look
at how many times
rock-paper-scissors comes
up in just papers that have been
published in the last 20 or 30 years;
there's an astonishing amount of
literature on rock-paper-scissors. And I
think- so one of the papers, the
really famous paper, was where they found
this rock-paper-scissor stuff in nature.
So there's a certain type of lizards
that use- well the way that the males
dominate one another follows a
rock-paper-scissors type game. There's
the orange lizards, these are the guys,
they're called ultra dominant, right;
they've got big territories, they've got
loads of females - they're the big guys,
right? Then there's the blue lizards,
their- their territory's much smaller
and you can tell the difference by the
way that their throats are coloured,
they're called side-blotched lizards. So
the blue lizards have much smaller
territories and fewer females who they
guard more carefully, and then the third
type of lizard is the
yellow lizard. They're kind
of roamers, they're called sneakers. So
they don't have any territory or females of
their own, but they can disguise
themselves as a female and go in to
attack one of the other territories. So
the orange lizards who have really big
territories, lots of
females, the sneakers,
the yellow lizards, can come in and steal
their females very easily. But the orange
lizards can steal females from the blue
lizards who have a very small territory,
obviously the big territory is really
attractive to the female lizards. So
that's kind of- the orange loses to
yellow but beats blue. Then the blue
lizard who lose to orange, they can't- the
yellow lizard has no way of attacking
their females because they're really
closely guarded. And actually a yellow
lizard will turn into a blue lizard
given half the chance, so the blue
lizards traditionally with his very
small loyal group of females does really
well. So in that- that's kind of the way
that the the sort of cyclic dominance
happens and it's ends up being, well,
exactly the same mathematically to a
game of rock-paper-scissors. They don't
have the sort of the human psychology,
shall we say, of choosing to play
strategies repeatedly, but because
there's this population what ends up
happening - you can
draw a little diagram, a
triangle diagram like we had for
rock-paper-scissors. Blue gets beaten by
orange, orange gets beaten by yellow, and
yellow gets beaten by blue. Now you can
think of this is as the populations of
the lizards; so let's say
if you're up here - this is
sort of like an axes, each of these
is like an axis. So if you're up
here the full
population is blue, they're all blue lizards.
If you're down here they're all orange
and so on.
So if you can imagine, if you start off
with a high population of blue lizards
there then becomes an advantage for the
orange lizards right? So the population
will kind of end up moving in this
direction. And then if you have more
orange lizards it becomes an advantage
for for yellow lizards, because they can
beat them, and so on. And you end up with
these trajectories that sort of end up
spiralling around. Now it depends on the
exact situation as to whether they form
closed loops or they spiral in or they
spiral outwards, and but this is kind of
the dynamics that you have in the
population of lizards. And it's exactly
the same as the traditional
rock-paper-scissors game.
You'd play scissors.
- (Do you play rock- do)
(you play rock-paper-scissors much?)
- Not really,
probably not since I was about 10.
(Shall we have one go?)
- Yeah go on then.
(Ready? On three, ready? One two-)